they came over for dinner I remember I
was in ripped jeans and I was barefoot
Megan Markle recalls meeting Prince
William and Kate Middleton for the first
time Barefoot and all now I know so much
and I'm so glad I didn't then because I
could just authentically be myself
without so much preparedness on Thursday
Netflix dropped the first three episodes
of the six-part docu-series Harry and
Megan and Meg gives insight into the
first time she met Harry's brother and
sister-in-law it was a hugger I've
always been a hugger I didn't realize
that that is really a
jarring for a lot of prints Megan says
she went in for the hugs and I think our
suspicions about this being a pretty
cool relationship right from the start
have have been confirmed here it also
confirms what we've always known which
is that Megan and Kate are two very very
different women you know that's why they
were never going to be best friends
there is a forward-facing way of being
and then you close it on your oh great
okay we can relax now but that formality
carries over on both sides
and that was surprising to me I think
that's all too easy to just
a lot of love and a lot of warmth in
that family as well of course Harry and
his brother have been at odds especially
after Harry's decision to step back from
his senior Royal duties in 2020. William
simply cannot forgive Harry not just for
leaving but for how he left and his
explosive tell-all interview with Oprah
Winfrey in 2021. there's clearly still a
lot of hurt a lot of resentment and a
degree of mistrust I think on both parts
and while Harry says his family was
impressed by Megan when they first met
her he claims there was one thing that
kept them from taking their relationship
seriously the fact that I was dating an
American actress was probably what
clouded their judgment more than
anything else at the beginning oh she's
American actress this weren't lost
the actress thing was the biggest
problem funny enough so how does the
Royal Family feel about the couple's new
project well the docu-series kicks off
with a disclaimer that reads quote
members of the royal family declined to
comment on the content within this
series but now a source tells E.T the
royal family is not aware of any such
approach for comment I'm told by a
senior Palisade it's a case of keep calm
and carry on and let's not get too
distracted by this meanwhile a Netflix
Source tells E.T that Communications
offices for King Charles and Prince
William were contacted in advance and
given the right to reply to the claims
in the series
et's asked the streamer for proof
here
[Music]
thank you